Speaker 1: I want to talk a little bit about the
Dr. Anthony Fauci email story and the reason I
haven't spoken about it yet is because I don't see
it as much of a story. But I received a few emails
over the weekend from people saying, David, what
do you think about the Foushee emails? So let's
talk about it a little bit today. Last week, The
Washington Post, as well as by BuzzFeed News,
published a bunch of emails in which Dr. Anthony
Fauci is either the recipient, the sender, or both
involved in a back and forth. And these are from
relatively early in the pandemic, February, March,
April. And the emails were obtained through a FOIA
request. And since these emails were released,
all sorts of conservatives and right wing
media have been saying, wow, these emails are
the smoking gun about the misdeeds of Dr.
Anthony Fauci. Rand Paul was talking about
these emails proving Foushee needs to be removed.
And it has become a big story among the right.
Now, I've looked at these emails, not all of
them, because there's 900 pages of emails,
but I've looked at the emails that the
right wingers believe are the smoking gun.
And the reason I haven't talked about it is
I can't find a smoking gun here. One aspect
of the emails is the so-called lab leak theory.
And the idea from the right is the emails prove
that privately Dr. Fauci was acknowledging this
could have come from a lab, this might be manmade,
could have come from a Chinese lab, even though
publicly Dr. Fauci was not saying that at the
time. That's the claim from the right. I looked
at the emails related to this. You can look
at them as well. To me, it only shows that Dr.
Fauci seemed open to people investigating this
as he remains today. But he didn't believe at the
time that the evidence pointed in that direction.
No such evidence had been presented to him. And
eventually you look in the emails, he gets emails
from others who start to agree, for example,
the immunologist Christian Anderson, who said,
hey, we should maybe look at this. And later
emails Fauci and says it's extremely unlikely
that the lab leak theory is the right one. It
just isn't compelling evidence that what Dr. Fauci
believed at the time was that the lab leak was
likely and that he was lying publicly. I just
couldn't find evidence of that by looking
at the emails. Second point of controversy
from the Foushee emails has been that initially
Dr. Fauci downplayed the need for the general
public to wear masks, even though eventually,
as we know, most people started wearing masks,
even if you weren't sick. Now, this has already
been sort of a Ligget litigated in the media.
And Dr. Fauci has since acknowledged the
reason for those initial statements was
in great part, motivated by wanting to prevent
a run on masks, which would then deprive health
workers of the masks combined with at the time,
they really didn't think anybody who was who was
not sick needed to wear them. To me, the emails
showed that Dr. Fauci, at least into February,
was privately saying the same thing he was saying
publicly, which is if you're not sick, you don't
need to wear a mask. So I do think there's a fair
criticism of Dr. Fauci for the mask stuff. But
it's been done. There's nothing new based on the
emails he's admitted to, why he said what he said.
And the emails don't change that. So I didn't find
a story there either. Other storylines from the
emails include the idea of some kind of offer from
Mark Zuckerberg to Dr. Fauci. Some right wingers,
including Laura Ingraham, have focused on
this, saying, what exactly was that offer?
It appears that what it was was an offer from Mark
Zuckerberg to work with. His team to tamp down on
disinformation about coronavirus on
Facebook, that's what it seems to be
the least charitable way to interpret that would
be that they were colluding to censor people.
But the offer was about apparently tamping down on
coronavirus disinformation, not a big smoking gun.
And then the other topic is hydroxy chloroquine.
The right has been claiming that privately,
as evidenced by these emails, Dr. Fauci knew that
hydroxy chloroquine could really work on covid.
But publicly, Foushee was saying it doesn't work.
The reality is, neither claim is true. The emails
don't show that Foushee thought it was a treatment
that worked for covid and publicly. Remember, all
Foushee was saying was we don't yet have evidence
from double-blind randomly controlled trials that
would suggest to us that hydroxy chloroquine is
a good treatment for coronavirus prophylactically
or in an acute sense, that's what he was saying
publicly. And there is nothing in these emails
that contradicts that. So that's my assessment of
the main controversies related to these emails. It
is those four lab leak masks, hydroxy chloroquine,
as well as the masks hydroxy chloroquine.
Nasse hydroxy chloroquine, which now I'm not
even looking at my notes here, censoring. Oh
yes. And the the the Facebook thing barely even
rates because it's so bizarre. Those were the four
controversies I found and none of them seemed like
a smoking gun. So if I've missed a controversy
for which these emails are the smoking gun, let
me know if you disagree with my assessment of
any of these four topics. Let me know as well.
I'm glad to revisit. I am just not seeing it.